all right Ariana
making money moves how are you
prioritizing what to do I think
everybody and everything is coming your
way
um I am in a position right now where I
just want to do everything and I really
am enjoying myself doing it as much as I
can with everything that's going on in
your world like how are you processing
all of it while you're getting to do
these really fun opportunities
um well I think something that's really
helpful is being really busy it's like I
have moments of processing moments of
feeling and then because I'm able to
like have something on the horizon to
look forward to that day or the next
week or whatever it's helping me to not
stay stuck can you clarify where you're
living right now I live in my house
it's a real life situation that a lot of
people deal with like what have people
been saying to you and what advice do
you have for people who need to look at
what you didn't do it um I think that so
many men and women have been in a
similar position that I have been or
that I am and I think the best thing I
could say is to just trust your
community your support system and let
people help when they offer to help and
just really lean on those people because
that's what's helped me the most the
fans my friends my family yeah and
honestly it's I think when you go
through something you know not just
something like this but any trial by
fire in in your life I think you realize
like how strong you can be and what
you're capable of and I think that
that's a lesson that I've learned in
this moment and I hope that other people
are able to feel that as well whenever
they go through something the Ariana
that we saw a couple months ago we're
going to see it tonight on TV but how
much have you changed the world has been
oh I mean I don't know I'm still me
to keep in mind
next four weeks of the show I think fans
I hope they keep in mind that the
reunion was shot on March 23rd a lot of
people I've seen online are like we're
sick of hearing about it or why is this
dragging out and it's like well you know
our show is shot over a course of the
summer and week to week you see
installments of that and so I mean I get
it but it's definitely it was where we
were on March 23rd I think mentally and
so
yeah I think that were we to film that
reunion today I don't know if everybody
would be on the same level but
um I definitely think that that's
something to keep in mind
I have actually not seen any of the
reunion yet will you be watching it
I think I should
aware of like what happened you know
just to see like how it is you get to
step into your next chapter now what do
you want to claim in what's left of 2023
for yourself
I want to lame Independence I want to
claim success I want to reclaim my time
I want to just I want to claim all the
Good Vibes and positivity and I want to
leave all the negative stuff in the past
we Second firmed That season 11 is
happening what does it look like
there's no way for any of us to ever
predict or plan I feel like anytime
anyone on our cast or anyone you know
tries to plan ahead for a season it's
it's impossible and nothing ever goes
according to plan so you might as well
just go and do it with an open mind and
just see what happens are you excited to
return I'm excited to return I mean
we've been sharing our lives on TV for
10 seasons nine for me and I think that
I'm just excited to keep doing that it
brings me a lot of joy to connect with
people via doing the show and so I want
to be able to keep doing that
foreign